I've had a lot of girls on the show and
typically they don't want a virgin I
would you like a virgin I've always
wanted to try a virgin
you're too old now but I would like
because I feel like if you're a virgin
like you're probably waiting for someone
special and like if you were to I think
it goes for me it goes both ways it's
like
oh like um
your DMs are gonna be fluffy oh my God
they're already going crazy
princess treatment first the princess
and then they're already in the chat
they're like they're a wiper
like you would want a virgin man for a
long-term relationship yeah so you would
prefer to teach a man how to have sex in
the bedroom yeah 100 I'd rather like him
be like oh my bit I think it's more
attractive if a man is too confident in
chatting to me leave because I know
you've chatted to the 10 girls in this
club already like oh this bar whatever
like it's two you're too skilled at this
right I want someone who comes to me
like my last ex like the first kiss we
had he was like shaking a bit I was like
you okay he's like can I kiss you and I
was like this is the sweetest thing I
think it's the sweetest thing when
someone's like really nervous because
obviously like it's not a like they
don't do it all the time so I don't
believe you yeah
it was welcome
yeah yeah do you know what it is
I think this generation of women have
become so masculine yeah that some
feminine behaviors in Men actually turn
them on wow that is that is what I
believe I believe that so many women of
this younger so this generation have
become so masculine that men acting like
women now turns them on and it's very
weird to me because it's like I don't
think it's acting like women it is
it's quite it's quite a feminine
everyone has everyone has masculine and
feminine inside them of course if you're
burying different degrees Yeah if you're
a man typically this is an exhaustive of
course typically you're gonna have more
masculine ends what do I look like yeah
you ever think about when feminism
advocates for men it only advocates for
men to benefit them because they want
them to be more emotionally available
say that again whatever feminism
advocates for men they only advocate for
men when it benefits them because they
want men to be more emotionally
available so it's really about the women
it's not the man stop it I would argue
that being emotionally available is good
for everyone yeah and not just the
matter especially if you choose to have
kids and emotionally available man yeah
it's a lot better than an emotional I
mean and you would think that from a
woman's point of view yeah yeah because
that's like yeah
I've got a caveat to that so in an
instance I agree with you but more so
than anything a man shouldn't be
emotionally available to his woman
because a woman more times than not
doesn't understand the complexities that
he goes through he should be emotionally
available to his male friends who he
should seek guidance from hundreds in
order to deal with the situations that
will come within this relationship and
I'm saying male friends that are
actually good and conducive to what he
wants and that way what happens is a
woman will feel emotionally
comfortable to come and open up to her
man because
he's he can be her Rock I feel like
women think they can do that you see
that guy that's a bit nervous that wants
to kiss you and I was like oh my God I'm
sure you see that guy there you know
that guy's not a protector exactly
somewhere in somewhere in you you know
that guy is a [__] he's gonna see a
spider you do you do you know that guy
is not confident he's not confident
um he doesn't really he doesn't get
girls he's not the type of he does he's
not the type of man he's not the type of
man that you step out in public with and
say okay this guy's gonna protect me
he's not that dude so at the end of it
at the end of the day it might be a
novelty for a certain point of so for a
certain for a certain time right but I
think in the long run you wouldn't even
respect that man
I'm just curious so the one you laughed
that's not because of it it's actually
he was we I don't want to State him
online
but that's not the reason like that's
the that's the reason I started dating
him and it's not that if he was like
I've there's boys who are very confident
there and that turns me right off like
it's the complete opposite it's just a
lot of times like what got the feedback
because I listen to men talk a lot and
so a lot of times what they say is like
what don't listen to what women say
because they'll say things watch what
they do and so so and this is the case
where you're saying this man was
emotionally available but the result was
still you laugh it doesn't mean that it
doesn't mean he was emotionally
available like that's a complete like um
the thing is women grossly underestimate
the platinum and they think they can
actually solve his problems but like
especially for feminine exactly
especially from an emotional point of
view like you really don't and can't to
a certain extent understand the plight
of a man and how what it's like for
people to only value you based on what
you can provide on a continual basis
yeah another man can understand that
because he's in the exact same situation
so if a man can actually you know
process his emotions using his other
male friends who are let's say further
down the line let's say these men have
successful marriages he can then go back
to his let's say newly married wife and
be like okay cool this is how it's going
to be this is he can he knows exactly
what to say and how to move and how to
maneuver right because he's gotten that
tutelage from older experienced men who
let's say are unsuccessful marriages I
really do think that women should not
run societies
why because return our rides baby
because you want to feminize men yeah
and you think you think feminine men are
gonna listen China and Russia are still
around yeah a bunch of feminine men
running around ain't gonna be good for
society because when it's wartime you're
gonna have a bunch of [__] running
around saying oh my God baby could you
go out and do the war no like what the
hell you need masculine men for an
actual reason and I think when women are
in charge they use their emotions more
so than they use their logic and so they
ask men to be like them which is why
when a woman women generally come to men
to have a conversation and say oh my God
babe do you know what happened at work
today and a man just like
because he you should talk to your women
friends like that I get it right but men
do not operate the same way you so how
would you like love your wife or whoever
you're dating to operate with you in the
home
how would I do what how would you prefer
her to operate with you in the home
if she's like just provide value and be
an asset yeah that's so vague like okay
cool like okay so if you wanna would you
talk to her at all like what would you
talk about it okay so okay okay so this
is the thing
so women women have a way in which they
speak to each other yeah so you see
earlier on when you said the
communication wasn't communicating yeah
right I'm like what the [__]
like so women have a certain language
that they have between one another right
and so what you have to understand is
men operate mentally and oh what the
hell is that like men operate
differently right when it comes to
um understanding and when it comes to
processing information we're very
logical like like I said if I'm gonna
talk to you bro I'm going to tell you
this this this this this boom Done Right
women are like when a woman speaks to
you she told me about her feelings first
all right so I was anyway I was on my
period right so you already know and
it's like it's a whole thing and I'm
just like
I ain't got men generally don't have
time for that type of conversation they
generally don't and I know you you're
probably thinking this is misogynistic
this is sexist but it's real like men
don't operate we don't speak like you
speak we don't communicate like you
communicate would you have dinner babe
cool I'll see you later then right
exactly
it's interesting what you said because
like you use the word misogynistic and I
think a lot of women conflate you know
someone trying to let them know that
their actions will have long-term
consequences and ramifications with you
hate me because right now I'm feeling
like you hate me no I don't hate you